And welcome to my session.
I'm going to be talking about V8 in the real
world, or more specifically in the native
script framework.
I'm Stanimira Vlaeva, I'm a software engineer
and work on this cool open source project,
NativeScript.
And I'm with web technologies, and find me
on Twitter, the best place.
Or in the karaoke after.
So, NativeScript.
Our main topic today after V8, of course.
What is it?
How many people here have heard about NativeScript?
Awesome.
Okay.
NativeScript is a framework for building native
mobile applications for Android and iOS using
web technologies.
Like Angular, Vue, or just plain JavaScript.
In short, it is a way to execute JavaScript
in the mobile world.
And build mobile applications with it.
We will take a short overview of the architecture
of the framework.
At the bottom, of course, we have Android
and iOS.
Operating systems.
On top of that we have the NativeScript run
times for Android and for iOS which provide
the 100% native API access.
But if you have had to build a native application
for Android or iOS, you may have noticed the
way to do that is quite different.
The APIs are different and the way to build
your user interface is different.
Everything is completely different because
they are two different worlds.
That's why NativeScript provides a common
abstraction for these APIs.
It is part of the framework and the NativeScript
developer cans use that in order to build
layouts or build user interface or even style
their applications with CSS and this layer
is written in JavaScript and you can use that
so that you can have a single codebase and
have different applications for Android and
iOS.
NativeScript also has a very light application
framework which provides us with native bindings,
navigations and some other cool things.
And if you need something a bit more sophisticated
while building your applications, NativeScript
also supports Angular and Vue JS.
Today we're gonna talk about the bottom most
levels.
The deep stuff.
And more specifically, we're gonna talk about
the Android runtime.
The two runtimes are quite similar.
And the biggest difference between them is
that the Android runtime uses V8 under the
hood whereas the iOS run time uses another
JavaScript engine.
JavaScript Core.
But the principle of how they work is quite
similar.
We're gonna start by explaining how the native
API access works.
As you make have guessed from the name ""NativeScript,""
this is kind of what we mostly brag about
because we have 100% API access.
And this is why you should be using NativeScript
instead of whatever anything else you choose.
The main advantage.
How it works.
We'll start with the look at the application
package of our NativeScript application.
So, we have Android, some phone or some device
that is running the Android operating system.
And the NativeScript application is just a
regular Android application and which has
some NativeScript magic inside it.
And the first part of the magic is, of course,
the JavaScript code that the NativeScript
developer wrote and shipped inside that application.
The JavaScript code is not cross compiled
or converted or anything like that, it stays
JavaScript during the whole life cycle while
the application is running.
We also have the NativeScript run time, both
in the Java part.
We're going to talk about them shipped together
inside the application.
And the last part, almost, is V8.
Why do we need to ship V8 inside an Android
application?
Well, to execute JavaScript.
V8 is a JavaScript engine.
It executes JavaScript.
It is embedded in Chrome, Note, even Microsoft
nowadays and of course in NativeScript.
It was developed by Google.
It was created from the Chrome browser and
it's one of the fastest JavaScript engines
out there.
Another reason why we chose V8 is because
it has a cool API that we can use and plug
into the runtime.
If you want to read a bit more about V8 and
how it works, I highly recommend these two
resources.
The first one is a really amazing popup series
which is a crash course just in time compilers.
And the other one is a video which is very
recent.
It's called why the script?
And describes the optimizations under the
hood while it executes your JavaScript code.
It's from the V8 team.
If you want to learn about modern JavaScript
engines, these are two great resources to
get started.
The next part of the NativeScript magic.
The metadata generator.
This is one of the very, very valid JavaScript
code inside of NativeScript.
But we have something that is not usually
in the JavaScript language, right?
Android.
Where does this come from?
Well, let's imagine that when your computer,
you have some native library.
For example, Android SDK.
And you use that inside your NativeScript
application.
While your application is being built, NativeScript
runs a special tool called the metadata generator
which traverses that native library and gets
information about the APIs.
It gets information about all the global packages,
about every single class, about how these
classes can be instantiated, about every method
in these classes and what are the meta signatures.
Basically, it gets information how every single
method and API can be used.
That is saved inside a compact runtime binary
which is, again, shipped inside the application.
So, we have information about how we can create
stuff in Java inside the metadata.
And the metadata of course is shipped together
with the whole application as well?
And what happens at launch time?
We initialize V8 which can execute the JavaScript
code.
We load the metadata from the files saved
inside the application and we attach source
and callbacks.
And the callbacks are the most important part
about embedding V8.
They are our way to plug into the JavaScript
code and do all sorts of stuff.
Let's start by explaining some stuff about
these callbacks and how they actually work
together with the metadata to provide access
with the native APIs.
Okay, we have this expression, Android media
recorder.
We are trying to execute that JavaScript code.
The NativeScript runtime has read the metadata
and found out that there is an Android global
package.
That's why it has created a global object
inside the running V8 instance for Android.
It also has attached some callbacks to that
object.
Like the package getter callback so that when
we query for Android.media, the NativeScript
runtime plugs in with that callback.
The callback will be executed.
And inside the callback the NativeScript runtime
will try to find Android.media inside the
metadata.
It returns something, some information, for
example, some information that Android.media
has some media recorder.
And it also has a package getter callback
attached.
So, when that callback is called, we find
the media recorder inside the Android media
package in the metadata.
And this time we return a constructer function
because this is actually a class.
And why is this constructer function so important?
Well, because when it's invoked with new,
it actually contains a constructer callback.
Again, attached by the NativeScript runtime.
And this is where the actual magic happens.
Because the NativeScript runtime creates a
native Java object.
But how does that happen?
Well, we use JNA, Java native interface, and
this is a bridge between V8 and the running
Android runtime.
So, we can save functions back and forth between
the two.
So, we create a native object.
Then we create the JavaScript proxy object
that we're going to discuss a bit later and
we return the proxy object to the JavaScript
world.
If it's right to access something inside that
proxy, well, actually this proxy object is
not very simple.
It's not a plain object.
It creates some callbacks.
Contains some callbacks as well.
So, when we try to access this random field,
we know that this field exists in the Java
world so that we have attached a field getter
callback.
And the field getter callback actually queries
the original Java object.
But there is a slight complication here.
Okay, we can get the result from the Java
world.
But the data type is different from the JavaScript
data type, right?
So, Java run string is not something we can
assign to a JavaScript variable.
And that is why there is a marshaling service.
To convert it from Java so to JavaScript and
vice versa.
At this point, you would say, wouldn't that
be terribly slow to convert everything?
Obviously, it will be, if it's to convert
object, it's not a good idea.
This is another reason why proxies are quite
useful.
So, for objects, we just create a plain JavaScript
object which has the same methods with the
same signatures.
And the same members as well.
And inside that we have callbacks.
So, that when you call some method with the
same name on the JavaScript object, the callback
will be called and the NativeScript runtime
will call the original Java method for JNA.
And this is a very cheap operation.
Creating new JavaScript objects.
Instead of converting data.
If you call a method, same story.
A method callback is triggered.
We call the original Java method.
The result is marshallized again and returned
back to the JavaScript world.
If we have arguments in that method, the arguments
will be converted to Java data format.
And then they will be the Java method will
be called with deconverted arguments.
Okay.
Let's see just a quick overview of all these
callbacks, if they are confused you so far.
We try to instantiate new object and assign
that to a JavaScript variable.
We call the constructer callback.
If you want to create a new instance of the
class through JNA.
The instance is returned.
And because it's an object, the NativeScript
runtime creates a JavaScript proxy object.
Then we try to call some methods on that proxy.
We call actually the method callback without
knowing that we are calling it.
Everything is hidden.
It happens behind the scenes.
But the method callback then calls the original
Java method.
The result that we can get is returned through
JNA and marshallized and returned back to
the JavaScript world.
That's all the communication magic that happens.
What you may be wondering at this point what
happens with these objects.
Like we create JavaScript objects.
We also create Java objects.
They are collected in some way.
So, we actually have to take care of their
life cycle.
And in JavaScript we don't have to manually
manage the memory.
There is a garbage collector that runs.
And it's always to retrieve the memory of
the unused objects.
It also has a nondeterministic nature.
We can't be sure when the garbage collector
will run.
And the other kind of complication is that,
well, the Android runtime also has a garbage
collector.
It's pretty funny.
So, we have two garbage collectors running.
We have objects in both worlds.
And that's one of the biggest challenges of
the NativeScript runtime.
We have to kind of try to synchronize that.
We have to ensure that no object is collected
if there is a living counterpart.
For example, if you create some Java object
through JavaScript, and then try to access
it, if the Android garbage collector collected
the native Java object, that sounds really
cool because you will try to access something
is that doesn't exist, and the application
will crash.
Like, it will crash.
Yeah.
You're running a mobile application and it's
not really cool user experience.
Okay.
In order to plugin into the life cycle, we
use finalizer callbacks so that when the garbage
collector of V8 marks something that for
collecting, says that some object doesn't
have living instances anywhere and it should
be collected, the finalize of the callback
will be called.
And this is the place where the script runtime
is plugged into.
We have strong and weak references.
Let's see how these actually look like.
We have the same example as before.
First, we create the native object.
Then we create the JavaScript proxy.
And then the NativeScript runtime has two
collections.
One for strong references and one for weak
references.
When the objects are first created, we create
a strong reference or a link, if you would
like to call that, between the two objects.
And if that's confusing, okay, the proxy lives
inside V8.
The original object lives inside the Android
runtime and the references live inside the
NativeScript runtime.
All right.
Time to collect stuff.
Some garbage collector runs.
We can't really say for sure if it's gonna
be the V8 garbage collector or the Android
runtime garbage collector.
But say in this example that V8 will decide
to collect the memory first.
So, there is no one in the JavaScript world
using the JavaScript proxy recorder.
And that's why it's marked for collection.
But at this point the finalizer callback is
called.
And the NativeScript runtime sees that there
is a living strong reference.
That's why the strong reference is turned
into a weak reference.
And we instruct V8 not to collect that object.
The next time when the Android garbage collector
runs, it decides to mark the recorder object
for collection because no one in the Java
world is using it.
And sees there's a weak reference.
And because it's a weak reference, this object
will be collected.
So, let's say that at some time the V8 garbage
collector runs again.
Well, now there is a weak reference.
And the weak reference doesn't point to anything.
And because we don't have anything out there
in the Java world, this object can also be
collected.
It's marked for collection and now we can
collect it.
But if we had two consecutive garbage collector
collection runs inside V8 and we still had
a weak reference to a living object that wasn't
created by the Java garbage collector, the
V8 object wouldn't have been collected as
well.
So, this is a normal cycle.
And as you could imagine, there are some challenges
that happen because we have two running garbage
collectors.
Well, we could get out of memory exceptions.
Usually the objects that were created in the
Android application are not really big.
So, we wouldn't have that happening for a
hello world application, right?
But the problem is that, of course, yeah,
we have a few garbage collection cycles that
should be run in order for some memory to
be retrieved back.
And if we create some big objects, this can
cause problems.
Because the memory is not retrieved on time.
For example, we can have images.
And an image let's say that this Java array
in the Java world.
The Java array is quite big.
Whereas the JavaScript proxy is not so big.
It's actually just a plain object with some
callbacks attached.
So, it actually looks like that, memorywise.
We have a lot of memory in the Java world.
We have a really plain JavaScript proxy.
And the Java the Android garbage collector
is actually dependent on the V8 garbage collector
in order to retrieve this huge chunk of memory.
So, at this point the V8 garbage collector,
even if you have tens of thousands of these
small, plain proxies, it doesn't have pressure
to be run.
Because we don't really take a lot of memory
in the running JavaScript virtual machine.
So, V8 doesn't really have a reason to trigger
garbage collection.
If that doesn't happen on time, well, we may
cause out of memory exceptions.
Because we're taking too much space in the
Java virtual machine.
Some solutions or more like strategies to
overcome this.
Because there is no straightforward deterministic
solution.
Because of the nature of the problem.
The first one, there is an API provided by
V8 that lets us instruct V8 about the memory
that is allocated inside of it.
So, in our case we can say to V8, okay, the
Android application that is running actually
uses this amount of memory.
And this memory is used because you have created
some JavaScript objects.
And the JavaScript objects are still pointing
to living instances in the Java world.
So, this should hint V8 to garbage collection
more often because it's aware that there is
more memory freed.
I mean, it works in practice, but we can still
get out of memory exceptions.
Another important thing, we are doing this
internally inside of a NativeScript runtime
so the NativeScript developers don't have
to use that.
And it is a technique used internally.
Another solution.
We can force garbage collection, of course.
We can say, V8, come on, run garbage collection.
Mark these objects as free to be retrieved.
Make these strong references weak.
Then we can run the Android garbage collector.
And then run the V8 garbage collector again.
This is not the best thing ever because it
doesn't guarantee that the garbage collection
will be run.
It kind of schedules it or hints it that it
But we don't have a guarantee that it will
be run.
And you don't have a guarantee that it will
be run in that order as well.
And it's not the cheapest option out there.
You are checking the objects and seeing if
they have living references.
It may have the opposite effect.
So, this is not the best solution ever.
You can do it.
It is some strategy, but we don't really recommend
using that.
Okay.
Let's take a look at this again.
We have a strong reference.
What didn't have references?
And what if we had the control over things
like this Java object can't be collected because
I'm not using it anymore, it can be collected.
I'm not using it in the JavaScript world.
Well, the NativeScript runtime releases a
function, release native counterpart and we
need to run the object, and it basically destroys
all these references.
So, we invoke that.
We basically instruct that we're no longer
using this native object and it can be retrieved.
So, whenever the next Android garbage collector
runs, it is no longer dependent on V8's garbage
collector.
It can mark this object and say retrieve it.
And as the last part of the presentation,
something like a bit simpler.
What is the point?
Well, the JavaScript code in NativeScript
is run and executed from a single thread.
Which actually happens to be the main user
interface thread.
And if you see where I'm going, this can cause
some problems with log and junk.
So, you can see some glitches while your mobile
application is being used.
And this is not the best experience for a
native mobile application as well.
So, first you know what is junk, probably.
It is the percentage of frames that are dropped
while you are doing some calculations.
We're not gonna focus on that.
It's important to know that in the NativeScript
application, if you are just building user
interface, you are creating native Android
and iOS widgets.
So, you shouldn't experience junk in a native
list view when scrolling, for example.
If you are creating animations, same thing.
You have many ways of creating in NativeScript,
with Angular, CSS, with JavaScript.
But internally it's actually creating native
applications.
So, you shouldn't have any problem while running
animations.
The other thing that is commonly we're commonly
asked for.
If you're creating an HTTP request, the plugin
that you're gonna use creates a background
thread in the Java world which wouldn't freeze
the main UI thread.
But you may see some junk when you're executing
CPUintensive operations.
And the same thing would happen if you are
executing CPUintensive Java code in an Android
application.
What is the solution?
Well, worker threads.
Essentially background threads to unlock the
main thread.
We don't have JavaScript memory sharing, but
we have a way to communicate between the worker
thread and the main UI thread.
And the final thing, I'm going to ask you
a question.
You have to be patient for 30 more seconds.
What is a worker thread in NativeScript?
Two hints.
Is it an isolate?
Isolate is V8's way to isolate and executes
some memory sorry to isolate some memory
for a code that's being executed.
They can run in parallel and we don't have
memory sharing.
Context.
One isolate can have multiple contexts.
We don't have member isolation and we can't
run contexts in parallel.
Also, you have to explicitly specify the context
that some code is being executed on.
Isolates or context?
Isolates.
Contexts.
Okay.
That's okay.
Isolates.
Okay.
So, isolate.
All right.
So, this was about NativeScript and V8.
If you want to meet me afterwards, you can
find me in Twitter, and I'll be coming to
you.
And I also want to thank my colleague who
helped me with this presentation.
And this is his handle on Twitter as well.
So, thanks a lot.
[ Applause ]